ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
WILL ALLOW BEGAN UMPS IF WE HAVE
A WE HAVE SOMETHING TO DO AT
ABOUT TEN O'CLOCK I THINK WE
SHOULD JUST BEGAN.
A WE DON'T ALL THE MEMBERS ARE
HERE WE SHOULD BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE SO MISTER TING AT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
PROPERLY.
AND I THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK FOR
BEING HERE SO ALL OF THE MEMBERS.
YOU COULD HEAR AT YOUR EARLIEST
CONVENIENCE BECAUSE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BEGIN SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN.
I THINK YOU'RE MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
AB SEVEN FOUR EIGHT IS A MEASURE
TO PROVIDE GREATER TRANSPARENCY --
IN A VERY NARROW SITUATION
REGARDING POLICE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT BODY CAMERAS AS YOU
KNOW -- WE
AS A STATE AND MANY MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SIX COUNTIES HAVE
STARTED TO INVEST A
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE TECHNOLOGY
OF BODY CAMERAS.
HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE A STATE
WIDE POLICY OFFICE OF OFTENTIMES
MANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WOULD
HAVE ANY POLICY.
AS TO WHEN A BODY CAMERA FOOTAGE
CAN BE OR SHOULD BE.
RELEASED WHAT WILL WE HAVE ON
DOT IS AMEND THE BILL INTO THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
AND DURING AN INVESTIGATION
FORSTMANN AGENCIES GIVEN
DIFFERENT TIME FRAMES ACTUALLY
TELL THE PUBLIC WHY THE
INFORMATION SHOULD NOT BE
RELEASED AND JUST THE THE
LANGUAGE FROM THE BILL.
IS THAT.
THE I. AGED AGENCY DEMONSTRATES
BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
THAT DISCLOSURE WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY INTERFERE WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
ON AND AGAIN --
REALLY WE WANT TO BALANCE THE
ABILITY OF EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY TO DO THEIR JOB DO THE
WORK BUT THE SAME TIME I BALANCE
IT WITH THE PUBLIC'S DESIRE TO
KNOW WHICH IS REALLY WHY --
WE HAVE AS A COMMUNITY MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY.
ARMED.
THE I AB SEVEN FOR IT ALSO ONLY
APPLIES.
IN INCIDENT IN WHICH THE USE OF
FORCE BUY PEACE OFFICER CRYSTAL
OFFICER AGAINST A PERSON
RESULTED IN DEATH OR IN GREAT
BODILY INJURY SO WE DEFTLY HAVE --
NARROWED THE BILL SINCE WE FIRST --
INTRODUCED IT TWO YEARS AGO --
VERY MUCH THINK THAT THIS IS A A
GOOD GOVERNMENT --
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE IT WAS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T
HAVE TO WITNESSES TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU NAM FIVE MINUTES TOTAL.
CALL FOR QUORUM.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY HERE.
CARRIER [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
MOST PRESIDENT YOU MOVE THE BELL.
YOU MAY PAN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AMBER'S NIKKI MORE WITH
A CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION HARRIS CO SPONSORS
OF AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT WHEN I
THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY AND ALSO
MENTIONED THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WHICH I WAS ISSUED
YESTERDAY THAT ANALYZE THE BILL
AND NOTED.
THAT THIS BILL REASONABLY
PROTECTS INDIVIDUALS PRIVACY
THERE ARE WE WENT TO GREAT PAINS
TO TAKE CARE OF THE PRIVACY
INTERESTS THAT ARISE WHEN YOU
HAVE -- THIS
DISCLOSURE OF THIS FOOTAGE IT
ALSO -- SO
IN OUR DEFINITION OF CRITICAL
INCIDENT IS LIMITED TO ONLY THAT
DISCHARGE OF A FIREARM OR A USE
OF FORCE THAT RESULTS IN SERIOUS
BODILY GREAT BODILY INJURY.
OR DEATH AND THE INVESTIGATORY
RECORDS EXEMPTION IN THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT SO THE REST OF THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT WILL STAY AND
TO PROVIDE OTHER EXEMPTIONS FOR
NON DISCLOSURE SO.
THIS IS ABOUT THE INVESTIGATORY
INTEREST AND AT SOME POINT THE
INVESTIGATORY INTEREST MUST AND
AND THEN THIS INFORMATION CAN BE
DISCLOSED BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PRIVACY EXEMPTIONS IN ON IN THE
LAW.
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THAT ARE
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE LAW.
ON AND THIS BILL IS MODELED
AFTER LAPD'S POLICY AND IT'S
ACTUALLY GOES FURTHER TO PROTECT
FROM DISCLOSURE INFORMATION THAN
LA PEACE POLICY.
SO I THINK IT'S A BALANCED
MEASURE THE PROTECTS EVERYONE'S
RIGHTS AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS A TECHNICAL QUESTION
TO BE HAPPENING TO THEM AND WE
ARE CHEN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PETER BE BRING DIRECTOR
POLICE PRACTICES FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
ARM IPAD CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL WILL BE VERY BRIEF JUST TO
SAY THAT THIS BILL IS NOW.
NARROWLY FOCUSED ON CRITICAL
INCIDENTS SO POLICE SHOOTINGS
AND OTHER INCIDENTS OF USE OF
FORCE WITH HIS GREAT BODILY
INJURY THOSE OF THE INCIDENTS
THAT ARE --
MOST IMPORTANT THERE FOR A
PUBLIC TRUST THE MOST IMPORTANT
FOR ACHIEVING A MEASURE OF
TRANSPARENCY FOR COMMUNITIES --
AND THIS BILL IS NOW NARROWLY
FOCUSED ON THOSE INCIDENTS --
AS MISS MORE MENTIONS OF IT IS.
IT TRACKS THE LAPD POLICY IT IS
WORKABLE AND IT ACCOUNTS --
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATION HAS A SYSTEM TO
AVOID --
INTERFERENCE AND TO RESPECT
PRIVACY AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN DISCOURSE ON
ZILLOW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WHEN
THIS BILL LEFT THE ASSEMBLY IT
WAS FAIRLY INNOCUOUS IT SAID IF
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE BODY CAN'T YOU
HAVE TO A POLICY ON THE LET
ANYBODY LAW ENFORCEMENT
CERTAINLY SHERSTON HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH THAT BILL.
GOT DRASTICALLY AMENDED IN THE
SENATE OMINOUS NOW BEFORE YOU
TODAY IN THIS FORM --
IT HAS BEEN NARROWED FROM THE
FORM THAT PASSED THE SENATE OR
FOR EXCUSE ME FROM THAT PASSED
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
BUT NEVERTHELESS IS A FAR
EXPANSION OF WHAT.
LEFT THIS HOUSE INITIALLY --
UP I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
WE BELIEVE THAT --
THIS BILL REMOVES AGENCY
DISCRETION WHEN IT COMES TO THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT BODY
CAM FOOTAGE SHOULD BE RELEASED
WE THINK THAT DISCRETION
PROPERLY LIES.
WITH THE AGENCIES --
THEY ARE BEST SITUATED TO MAKE
THAT DECISION --
THIS BILL WHILE IT ALLOWS.
TWO ALLOWS ME TO SEE WITH HOLD
DISCLOSURE --
FOR FORTY FIVE DAYS BUT AFTER
THAT FORTY FIVE DAYS THE AGENCY
IS REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THE
REQUEST FOR EVERY THIRTY TO EASE
IN PERPETUITY UNTIL THEY DECIDE
TO RELEASE THE FOOTAGE.
AND SO BECOMES A PRETTY BURDEN
SOME --
IMPACT IF THERE IS A IF THERE'S
A REASON FOR THE FOOTAGE TO BE
WITHHELD --
BE AGENCY HAS TO CONTINUALLY --
IT AGAIN IN PERPETUITY BY THE
PERSON THAT THEY'RE NOT
RELEASING IT AND THE REASON FOR
THE WITHHOLDING.
TOM BUT I THINK OVERALL WERE
CONCERNED THAT OVER REGULATING
BODY CAN USAGE --
COULD HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT ON
THE DEPLOYMENT BODY CAMS AND
BECAUSE THE AUTHOR OR THE
COMMITTEE'S INTENT --
BUT WE WE FEAR THAT ITEM OVER
REGULATION OF THIS UP AND COMING
TECHNOLOGY --
COULD RESULT IN AGENCIES
DECIDING NOT TO DEPLOY --
THOSE SYSTEMS AND WE THINK
THAT'S A MISTAKE SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK YOU KNOW VOTE
THANK YOU.
YES MORE IN CHAIR MEMBER SEAN ON
WITH CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WITH WITH SUMMERS
SIMILAR SENTIMENTS TO OUR MR
SOUTH THOUGH IN TERMS OF THE
REGULATION OF BODY CAMS.
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONWIDE ACTUALLY WERE USING
BODY COMES LONG BEFORE YOU EVER
HEARD OF YOU KNOW BOB FERGUSON
OR TRAYVON MARTIN ARE.
A LOT OF THOSE NATIONWIDE DE
EVENTS.
SO THAT THE DESIRE FOR
TRANSPARENCY IS THERE DESPITE --
SOME SENTIMENT TO THE CONTRARY
BUT THE APPROACH --
TO IT WITH THIS BILL --
IMMIGRANTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES NEED TO WORK WITH THERE
A LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE
PROPER HANDLING AND RELEASE OF
EVIDENCE WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT
THIS SAYS.
DESPITE SOME OF THE NARROWING OF
OF THE DEFINITION OF CRITICAL
INCIDENTS WE STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH WITH --
THE NON DEFINITION OF
SUBSTANTIALLY INTERFERE DURING
THE FORTY FIVE DAYS AND AFTER --
AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT UNDUE
BURDEN -- ON
THE LOCAL AGENCIES IN AND HOW
THE DO WITH THAT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NATIONAL CURRENT
MEMBERS PART NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AS CHAIR REMEMBERS
RAINY PERRY --
WITH VARYING ASSOCIATES UP HALF
A POOR AND COMFORT ASSOCIATION A
PATROL IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS NOT RECYCLING ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE ASSOCIATION FOR LOS
ANGELES DEPUTY SHARES BOTH
OPPOSED THANK YOU [inaudible]
EDU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MERSHON
OFTEN WITH CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION ALSO WITH
A ON THE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION TODAY.
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
CHARACTER ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES MISTER QUIRK SO I TRIED THIS
A COUPLE YEARS AGO I THINK THIS
IS A ARE.
A GOOD BILL.
ARM I THINK IT'S MORE
SOPHISTICATED THAN MINE IT WAS
AND THAT'S ONE REASON WHY IT'S
GOT AS FAR AS IT IS LET'S GET IT
OFF THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I THINK YOU --
I JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS SO
IF THERE IS PENDING LITIGATION --
THE VIDEO RECORDINGS WOULD NOT
BE RELEASE IS THAT TRUE OR NOT.
WE WE DEFIANCE PENDING
INVESTIGATION.
AND WHAT THAT BUT THERE HAS TO
BE IS TO HAVE TO BE --
THAT HAS TO COME THAT THE AGENCY
HAS COME FORWARD AND TELL US WHY.
RIGHT THEY HAVE TO PROVE TO THE
PUBLIC THAT THERE IS A SPECIFIC
REASON WHY.
A WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS PLACE
IS THE PROPER AMOUNT OF
AUTHORITY IN THE AGENCY CONTROL --
WE ALSO --
THE STATEMENT POLICY IS IN MY
OPINION MORE PERMISSIVE THEM BUT
THE LA POLICE COMMISSION ADOPTED.
A WHICH DOES ACTUALLY --
SET A SPECIFIC TIME FRAME FOR WE
DID NOT DO THAT IN THIS IN THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND SO --
NGUYEN TALKING ABOUT THESE KINDS
OF ISSUES AND THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION IT IS TRUE WE DON'T
NECESSARILY WANT TO RELEASE ALL
KINDS OF INFORMATION THAT PUT
POLICE OFFICERS IN JEOPARDY
BECAUSE THEY ARE HERE FOR A
REASON WHICH IS TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY AND THERE ARE
NEIGHBORS.
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT I'M ESPECIALLY IN HIGH
PRICE PROFILE.
INCIDENTS --
WORDS.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME OTHER.
CULTURAL AND SOCIAL
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
HAD IT'S A WAY FOR THE PUBLIC --
TO JUST HAVE A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION AND SO WOULD YOU
KIND OF AGREE WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT I THINK THAT'S UPS
ARISES SO ON DID THIS HAS BEEN A
TO YOUR BILL SO I DO APPRECIATE
THE OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS BUT
THIS IS A BILL THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORK ON FOR TWO YEARS.
HAVE HAD --
INTO MONTHS AND MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATION TO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THE DISCUSSION
THAT HAS GONE ON AT THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY WHY WE NARROWED --
SITS AB SEVEN FOUR EIGHT TO
SPECIFICALLY USE OF FORCE --
AND TO ONLY ON STATEWIDE IN THAT
PARTICULAR INSTANCE WAS NOT FOR
EVERY SINGLE.
TYPE OF SITUATION THAT IS GOING
ON PER BELIEVE FOR THE
SITUATIONS THAT PROBABLY HAVE
THE GREATEST AMOUNT COMMUNITY
INTEREST [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GREW [inaudible]
CARE.
SOMETHING ON YES HELLO GOOD
MORNING --
AS A FORMER JOURNALIST WHO HAS
BEEN COVERING --
SOME OF THAT THE RISE AND SOCIAL
MEDIA POLICE SHOOTINGS AND HOW
THE PUBLIC --
INTERPRETS THAT INFORMATION I AM
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S NECESSARY AND
IMPORTANT I'M ALSO PROUD TO SEE
I'M ALSO HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
CO SPONSORS OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION.
AND ONE OF THE OTHER SUPPORTERS
IS THE CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
WE'RE LIVING IN A TIME IN WHICH
THE GENERAL PUBLIC ITS
INFORMATION RAPIDLY.
AND SO THE WAY IN WHICH THE
RESPONSIBLE NEWS MEDIA TELLS
THOSE STORIES AND HAS ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO
BE MORE INFORMED.
INFORMED OPINIONS.
THAT -- CAN
ACTUALLY GET TO AN END RESULT
VERSES SOME OF NOT KNOWING
UNKNOWN CIRCUMSTANCES THE
PROTESTS THAT WE'VE SEEN ON THE
STREET ON THE THE TENSION
BETWEEN THE PUBLIC AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
CARE ABOUT WE WANT TO ECHO.
MY COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS WE ALL
BELIEVE THAT ONE IS THERE TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE LIVING IN A
TIME IN WHICH SOCIAL MEDIA ALSO
PLAYS A ROLE IN HOW THE STORIES
ARE TOLD SO I I I AM I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT UP SOME OF THE CASES
TRAYVON.
MARTIN UNFORTUNATELY WAS NOT A
TO YOUR POINT WAS NOT A CASE IN
WHICH LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
INVOLVED THAT WAS A CIVILIAN
THAT FELT THAT A YOUNG BOY
CARRYING A CAN OF I STIAN
SKITTLES WAS A THREAT TO HIS
LIFE AND FLORIDA'S STAND YOUR
GROUND LAWS ARE VERY DIFFERENT.
THAN WHAT THIS IS ABOUT BUT I
THINK ABOUT THE CASES OF FREDDIE
GRAY.
IN BALTIMORE I THINK ABOUT.
A OF THE CASES IN NEW YORK
WITHOUT HIM THE GENTLEMAN WHO
SAID I CAN'T BREATHE ERIC.
ERIC GARDNER THANK YOU.
AND OF THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
CASES THAT WE'VE SEEN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE BEEN BALD.
THIS TYPE OF SITUATION AND IF WE
HAD.
THE LAW IF WE HAVE THE BODY
CAMERA.
FOOTAGE THAN MAYBE THE PUBLIC
WOULD HAVE HAD A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AND WE'D GONE TO A
DIFFERENT SPACE BUT THIS IS
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND WE HAVE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE INFORM THE PUBLIC AND
HOW WE MAKE [inaudible]
DECISIONS.
THAT --
BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY AND AND
THE WAY THE CALIFORNIA WORKS IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE DO AND HOW
RESPONSIBLE WE ARE PLEASED A
ROLE FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
SO.
I'LL BE VOTING YES ON THIS BILL
I THINK IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER CHENEY
WITHOUT DISRESPECT RESTAURANT
OUT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS TO QUESTIONS TODAY.
AND THANK YOU SHOOTING YOU KNOW
IT WHEN IT FIRST HAPPENED.
I EVEN THOUGHT OF MY OWN BODY
CAM.
POLICY AND PROCEDURES THAT ARE
PUT FORWARD AND I WANTED I
WANTED TO PUT FORWARD.
WAS THE AGREEMENT WILL BE
BETWEEN MY OWN CITY THE LOS
ANGELES --
POLICE COMMISSION AND A LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS AN EXCELLENT --
WAY OF IMPLEMENTING BODY CAMERAS
AND A WHOLE POLICY.
OF I NEVER GOT A CHANCE TO MOVE
FORWARD A LOT OF PEOPLE BEAT ME
TO THE GUN.
BUT IT IT IT SHOWED ME AT THAT
TIME WE WE COULD HAVE A GOOD
DIALOGUE ABOUT HOW TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
I ALSO REMEMBER AND SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WERE HERE BEFORE
GIVES DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW
COSTLY IT WAS HOW WE COULDN'T --
KEEP INFORMATION AND AND THAT
DEPARTMENTS WOULDN'T IMPLEMENT.
DEPARTMENTS ARE IMPLEMENTED
RIGHT NOW ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT A
LAW.
WITHOUT HIS FORTUNE AND MATCH TO
ME I THINK THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
GREAT THAT REMOVING.
FOR WHAT WAS MISSING
[inaudible]
STATEWIDE GUIDELINE.
AND AND ALTHOUGH JUSTICE MAY NOT
BE THAT MAY NOT GONE AS FAR AS I
WOULD LIKE.
I THINK IT HAS BEEN WATERED DOWN
THERE'S A THERE'S A DISTANT
THINGS IN HERE I THINKHELP BOTH
SIDES I'VE HEARD FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THAT BECAUSE OF BODY CAMERAS --
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICES WHO'VE
BEEN WRONGLY ACCUSED.
OF CRIMES CAN NOW PROVE.
BEYOND A SHADOW OF A DOUBT THAT
THEY DID NOT USE RACIAL EPITHET
THEY DID NOT BEAT SOMEONE OR
THAT.
THEY DID NOT.
IT WOULD NOT OUT OF POLICE
POLICY BECAUSE THEY CAN NOW SEE
THE BODY CAM --
FOOTAGE AND SO I THINK IT WORKS
BOTH WAYS ON TO PROTECT OFFICERS
AND ALSO TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND THEN LASTLY AS PUBLIC
OFFICIALS I I CAN TELL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL.
WE MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR PROTECTION
OUR SAFETY AND THE SAFETY OF OUR
OUR FAMILIES.
AND ON PAGE SEVEN WHERE YOU
WRITE WHAT YOU HAVE ON IF TO
SUBJECT WHOSE PRIVACY IS TO BE
PROTECTED.
IS DECEASED.
AND AIR BENEFICIARY DESIGNATED
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER
AUTHORIZED LEGAL REPRESENTATIVE
DID TO SEE SUBJECT WHOSE PRIVACY.
IS TO BE PROTECTED.
THOSE OF US WHO'VE HAD OUR
PRIVACY.
BECAUSE OF STANCES WE'VE TAKEN
ON CERTAIN LAWS AND HAVE OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
I WOULD YOU SAY TORTURE OR GONE
AFTER SEE THE MADERA FACES ON
THE INTERNET WE KNOW WHAT THAT'S
LIKE AND SO WE WOULD NOT WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN TO ANYONE.
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SO IN
MANY WAYS WE SHARE.
A LOT OF THESE PRIVACY CONCERNS
WITH WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AS WITH THAT THE CHAIRS
RECOMMEND AYE VOTE --
AYE AYE.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK WE DO
HAVE TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
FORMERLY FROM ALONG.
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND THIS
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO TO DO
GIDDINESS THEIR CALDERON.
AND EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO BE CURTAIN JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY KNOW CARILLO.
GALILEO AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT PUBLIC SAFETY COMES
THROUGH ADJOURNMENT